here's Justin Greening with her
perspective on Liz truss's speech
I thought it was a
trying to achieve as a prime minister I
think it mirrored a lot of messages that
she had put out there during the
conservative leadership campaign I think
maybe the challenge also though is that
in a sense it hasn't addressed any of
those fundamental gaps that we saw open
up during this Conservative Party
Conference this sense that almost we got
to the end of a leadership contest and
yet it feels I think for the public like
somehow it's still going on in the in
the conservative party right now
I have to say uh I've been to quite a
lot of conservative party conferences in
my time quite old now but I haven't
really been to one quite like this uh
Liz truss abandoning her Flagship one of
her Flagship policies the 45p uh
abolition of that rate of tax 24 hours
after defending it and then since then
it's been a free-for-all with different
cabinet ministers coming out commenting
on different policies has the prime
minister's Authority completely gone
I think it's really difficult Sophie
you're right from my perspective you
could see this U-turn coming down the
track really the week before obviously
to have it at conference was probably
the most damaging time you could have it
um as an incoming prime minister and I
think the concern from my perspective
was when you listen to people like
Michael Gove talking about his
opposition to it it was very values
based actually it wasn't just about a
narrow policy question on 45 Pence
um the income tax rate and sure enough
the next day we then moved on to a
debate about whether benefits should be
upgraded in line with inflation so
my concern for the party is that there
are these different camps that
fundamentally have different views and
different values perhaps about where
they want the party to go and that
doesn't just get resolved by one or two
policy policy shifts and I think that's
the debate that we'll go back into
Parliament when everybody arrives back
in the House of Commons on Monday next
week
I'm interested to know your own position
on this you know when you're in
Parliament you're always someone who
championed social Mobility uh for
example
um what side of the debate are you on
so you're right I mean for me any of
these policy questions I would look at
through the lens and does this help
Drive Social Mobility does it help Drive
leveling up there's no doubt that when
you look at the benefit situation
actually people slipping into debt
is often very hard for them to get out
of and therefore making sure we mitigate
that risk that people are really worried
about over the coming months I think is
very important so that the benefits
question I think it is important from my
perspective that that stays in line with
inflation but of course this is a debate
for the the Parliamentary party this is
very clear that she didn't believe in
more handouts and so I don't think the
position she's taken so if he's a
particular surprise I think on the
broader package obviously doing the cost
of living package made sense I would
have liked to see I said this on your
program in the summer her and Rishi
sunak come together on that earlier in
the summer have got that out of the way
and that probably would have brought her
much more time as an incoming prime
minister to work out a full growth plan
that included how she was going to pay
for the measures as well as setting out
the measures in more detail and I think
it's been mixing up and muddling in a
sense those things things together
that's been extremely difficult for I
think the key thing frankly from my
perspective that I still want to see
from this incoming government is a much
more ambitious plan on skills I'd
actually like to see in emergency skills
budget
that addresses key issues that are
holding back growth like the fact that
the apprenticeship Levy itself for
businesses is stopping them from
investing billions of pounds in
developing skills there's some really
practical issues there Sophie I hope
that once people are back in Parliament
that they can then get on and set out
what they're going to do as a new
government to deal with them it's been
an incredibly difficult beginning for
Liz truss as a prime minister I think
that is absolutely cleared she's had a
u-turn on some of her policies already
she's her under her Authority has been
undermined by some people around her in
cabinet we've seen poll leads for labor
that we haven't seen since the early
days of Tony Blair do you think there's
any chance that the conservatives could
win the next election with Liz
trussell's prime minister
I think you could you can always have
some chance of pulling things around
turning them around if you'd said to
um labor activists after the 2019
election when they had this huge
Landslide defeat by Boris Johnson what
that they'd be 33 points leader they
changed leader though
true but again you look at kirstama he
was won by election away Batley and
spend from probably being replaced so
all we know Sophie is that politics is
extremely febrile but the bottom line is
whatever the politics this is a time of
Crisis for Britain economically there's
the war in Ukraine what people actually
want to see is the conservative party
now coming together it's had its
leadership contest it cannot keep on
going so those differences need to be
resolved one way or another in
Parliament that's not just something I
want to see that's a lot of the
activists I spoke to at Conservative
Party Conference want to see that too
because the most important thing is
actually less the party and more the
fact that it's a party in government and
it needs to deliver on addressing many
of those crisis issues that people are
really worried about day in day out at
the moment in The Wider country